you should be really careful when
getting advice along the lines of
you know only follow your passion do
what your heart feels and so on okay
because i think
those are pretty much you know those are
the snowflake type approaches where you
you find the one person that succeeds
welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford when thinking of non-linear
career pathways
i think of yair lifshitz former director
of cisco silicon one sdk
yaer started attending the technion
during high school then dropped out of
both
he became the youngest principal
engineer at intel israel and later led
the design and development of cisco's
silicon one sdk from inception to
production
yair is now partially retired dividing
his time between family
mentoring and writing it beyond good and
evil.org
how are you today i'm doing great where
are you in israel right now where are
you calling from
so i live in a village called it's on
the way to the
to jerusalem would you take one of the
you take one of the exits there
you get to that amazing
yeah we i'd love to talk about your
journey you start out with
you know going to to traditional high
school but not necessarily fitting in
exactly the way that
you know that the average kid i think
hopes to to fit in
you obviously go to the technion
and and attempt over there but also that
is not exactly the experience that
you're thinking of
but nevertheless you end up being an
executive in tech
leading teams uh for for some of the
most fantastic companies
and today you consider yourself so sort
of semi-retired
and spending quality time with your
family and friends and community
so you're taking me all the way back to
your school days and and what i'd really
love to do over these 20 minutes is to
just pick your brain over
your own experience and how that and how
a lot of
other young entrepreneurs and young
students might
you know resonate with the things that
you're saying because i think that a lot
of people are feeling what you're
feeling and it's
almost sort of a taboo subject sometimes
to speak about
definitely so let me just start by
saying that you know hindsight's 20 20.
so the way i'm seeing some of the things
you know when i look back
it's not necessarily the way i felt
those when they actually happened
okay and that's uh i think
that's also an interesting topic but uh
so for me i'm originally from uh
a small village in the north of israel
it's called amirim it used to be
still is a vegetarian village okay so
almost everyone living there were
actually vegetarian when i was born
um my dad's a farmer my mom's a
kindergarten teacher
um i think when i was much younger i
used to i think maybe
until the sixth or seventh grade i used
to go to the school you know
half and half or so on i would wake up
in the morning and tell my mom
you know i don't want to go to school
today and
i'm not sure why but they would let me
stay home and i would just
i don't know but like every kid
i i i don't know how many how many
people remember the
early math programs we used to have you
know the the educational tv we
used to have in israel so i would just
you know wake up in the morning
watch a few you know watch a few hours
of these math lessons english lessons or
whatever
or just walk around the village to do
something okay
um well then i i you know i i moved to
high school um i think i was uh
i don't want to say i was a lazy kid but
i probably was pretty much a lazy kid
i i remember everyone studying with me
you know we were
sort of a group of the you know of
the students that typically had uh
higher grades and so on
so i remember when we reached the 10th
grade and you have to choose
which what subjects you're going to
focus on so i remember everyone's saying
yeah i'm going to
i'm going to learn more about math and
physics and
you know and history and biology and
whatever each such kid had you know
three topics or i just said listen we
have to pick one so i'm picking
physics math isn't obvious that's it i'm
just getting home as early as i can
every day
that's fine for me um i think actually i
was pretty
and i'll be expected it is what it is
doing more
is not necessarily an upside but
and today i can say i don't think i've
seen it then but like
at least for me i think that's also a
misconception yeah
i i think i've seen that for many people
but i think definitely for me
most you know most types of
understandings or thoughts i have
you know do not happen since i sit
down and you know and methodically think
about a subject
you learn something then there's some
time when
things get you know they just getting
they are placed nicely in your brain and
then a day after
a week after a month after you wake up
one day and things are clearer now i
think if
if you want to see uh maybe one example
of how that works you can look at
you know how people are sometimes
stressed out up by
subjects they're studying in you know in
college or in high school
and then when they look at the same
subject a couple of years later
you know or maybe even a semester later
and they suddenly help someone else
suddenly everything is clear so
obviously there's no there's a
curve here and maybe if earlier you
understood 30
now you understand 50 okay or 80 percent
but for me i never you know it was never
in at least
back then there was never an and right a
take of hey i have to understand to
learn everything and so on
if if something was interesting for me i
would spend 24 7 on it
i remember as a kid i used to to go
online and just for example i
loved mathematics i used to read about i
don't read about the
biographies of euler and stuff like that
but if something's interesting you do
that if it's not interesting
then yeah then it becomes a sort of a
chore okay um
and by interesting i think interesting
is a tricky word so that doesn't
necessarily mean
this is something that you know that is
just like an interesting movie to see
sometimes you have a goal that's going
to take you two or three years to
achieve
okay so the interest doesn't have to be
that specific work you're doing that
specific minute
but you have to feel that that what
you're doing is significant
and that you are comp you know that you
are happy or
are content to doing it okay and if
you're doing something that will take
you three years or five years or ten
years to reach
but you feel comfortable with that and
again comfortable doesn't mean physical
comfort comfort master and doesn't mean
sleeping a lot of hours
and that's great and the more you
diverge from you know from your
sense of self the harder it becomes and
again this is not a i think my general
take on life is you know that
it's it's not you know right or wrong or
just words so it's uh
you have to make sure that what you're
doing is something that actually works
well for you
okay and and that can be sometimes it
can be working 24 7.
sometimes it can be just staying home
for a month and doing nothing both are
fine
okay um so anyways um
i think around the 10th grade uh a few
of the folks that i
studied with right so here i i really
want to ask you is
you know the the whole idea of you know
following your passion when you're when
you love something you do 24 7. you know
so you know it's great when that passion
is mathematics and computer science
because one
you're going to make a big impact on the
world and you're probably going to make
a lot of money along the way
but a lot of people have true true
passions that aren't
necessarily in those sexy fields that
every parent
would dream their kid to to to go and be
a doctor and a lawyer and a
mathematician
and and i completely agree with that
with that mentality that at the end
you know it's about finding that sweet
spot finding that particular passion
that
that you want to spend 24 7 on on an
intrinsic motivation
and if you if you spend the time that
you do
on things that you love you'll make the
most out of it you'll you'll be
successful with
it but it's really hard as a kid so
take me back again to your childhood how
do you cope with that how do your
parents cope with that and
and what sort of insights do you have
now for for young students that are you
know finding themselves in
in today's world in 2021 yeah so i think
maybe one thing
before actually touching on that one one
thing that i think is
at least is you know my take on life and
that is that
you should be really careful in getting
advice along the lines of you know
only follow your passion do what your
heart feels and so on okay because i
think
those are pretty much you know those are
the snowflake type approaches where you
you find the one person that succeeds
and or
the ten people who succeeded and you
know you know you're looking at
uh i don't know you're looking at steve
jobs right
so and there's this famous quote he has
where he says you know we don't hire
people to tell them what to do we hire
smart people so they tell us what to do
and that's great
but jobs were a micro manager and a
super micro manager right
and everyone in the field knows that and
i think if you work with some uh
you know with some uh top talent you
know that there is a huge
there you know there's a huge gap and
i'm sure by the way the jobs actually
felt that and that for some of the you
know maybe
maybe the people he trusted most i know
maybe for johnny ifc actually did that
okay but apple doesn't have two
employees it has
tens of thousands and those people may
have suffered a lot doesn't mean they
didn't enjoy
the end result but but it's the same
thing here if
you know if you look at me and you say
hey this person follow it is hard
everything
turned out okay then doesn't necessarily
mean that it will work for you and i've
made some choices in my life
where i said listen this choice is not
making
me happier on a day-to-day basis i'm
still going to keep at it for a while
because i think overall this is a good
decision i think this is something you
know this is
super critical understanding the fact
that those
simple advices along the lines of just
do what you want everything will be fine
and so on
at least my take is that it doesn't work
that way at all
okay what is true is that
you need to make sure at least that
that's my thing you need to make sure
that the
the path you follow is one that will
ultimately do
ultimately lead you as close as you can
to
my
for example my wife's a doctor okay i
don't think i would ever be able to work
as a doctor
okay but uh if that makes her happy
that's great if there's money in it
great if there is not it's
also okay you just need to make sure
that the balance of everything
the work your work your your children
your
family anything else that you care about
that you maximize that
balance and more importantly i think
that's maybe the key point and something
that
we are rarely taught is being able to
look at what you have objectively and
actually be content about it okay
to think uh and i can give maybe give
one example from
from myself that is a tricky one so
i don't know i i've joined sometimes
late in my career i joined the startup
it got acquired pretty quickly so i'm no
i'm
pretty okay now you mentioned retirement
so i'm at least on my first retirement
i'm sitting home taking
care of the kids with kovit it's even
better uh
so so so so so
so that works great but you know what
many once in a while i ask myself and
once in a while can be every
week or every month so so one thing i
asked myself
listen did i i mean did i really reach
my full potential
or not i mean and it can be anything
maybe maybe
hitting that jackpot with a startup was
you know the the best i can ever do and
maybe it was
actually a substandard result and going
with a different path in life i could
have achieved
much more i worked for intel for many
years was that a good
thing or a bad thing and it's really
hard to nail those things you know
there's that
fear of missing out whatever you do
you're always going to feel
or you're always going to be able to
feel that you could have done better or
there could have been something else
better and i think being able to quiet
that down that feeling whether that's by
objectivity being able to look in the
world and say
hey things you know i'm actually well
off or alternatively saying
i don't really matter i don't really
care about that there's
you know i don't mind the the
know the the reference to other people i
just want to know what makes me happy
it's a it's super hard to do that okay
and
i think that's actually what's leading a
lot of the frustration that we're
seeing around us so that's something
that you definitely focus on okay for me
i can just say that
most of the decisions i made at least
early both
dropping out of high school uh maybe
dropping out of high school that that
was the
the that was the one where i had the
least
amount of actual of an understanding of
what i'm doing okay the fact that this
worked out is
great but right right
yeah and i can say look looking like
that's 100 so
you're now in hindsight you know you you
it's okay what i wanted to ask is
in hindsight so you drop out of high
school
you make your way to the technion i
believe you you know you commute like
crazy amount of hours every day you also
don't find a good fit in a technion and
then you go to work for for intel for 10
years you lead a team at cisco what
do you feel that you were missing some
things um
that you were missing some things when
you entered the tech ecosystem that
did you did you missed some foundation
from academia
some theory or i mean now i'm talking
specifically to young
computer scientists or young engineers
that that you know are really excited at
1314 to just go and you know build stuff
for companies
and and might choose to forego that you
know four-year academic program in
university
or even doing a full high school diploma
yeah so i i i
i would split that into several things
high school diploma by itself is
meaningless
okay uh and i think the best reference
for that
at least you know at least work-wise and
the best reference for that
is the fact that you can see someone
studying for three or four or six years
you know for his matriculation exams and
then later you see people after the army
that have to redo those tests
or learn those from scratch and it takes
them two months okay so
that by itself i think is isn't is not a
key value
and no one actually at least work-wise
no one actually looks at that
again in the tech industry about the
technion i would say there's a
difference between
not doing something and doing it do you
know
just not doing something doing it
reasonably
well and actually doing it very well
okay so for the time i was at the
technion
i initially started studying uh math and
computer science
um i think i had i had high grades i was
enjoying the content it's not that i was
suffering there
the first the first i know year or year
and a half was really fun
okay um the moment i decided to quit i
already had the initial
you know the the basic uh the basic
background of things like
data structures algorithms and so on and
since i was
you know since i was part of the math
department then you actually
also hear about the motivation for
everything how how the underlying
uh logic of everything works and i think
that for me was uh
that blew my right so the moment you
have these basic
tools of what logic actually is what is
what does it mean that
a implies b and so on the moment you
have those things
and you you basically develop critical
and
objective thinking then you have this
tool now you can choose whether to use
it or not so i think the moment you have
these and
a few of the others data structures and
so on at that point
99 of the jobs in tech are doable and
the others
if you're a person who learns himself
you you you can
you can you can learn you can complete
this i'll just say that for me and
my path here was unique in one extra
sense
and that's because i live you know far
from you mentioned that i used to
commute a lot so before i started
studying at the technion i actually
spent a semester or two
uh studying at a community college
somewhere near my home
and i can tell you that i did not
understand anything
okay i think we did something equivalent
to algebra 101 there
i just did not understand anything you
know i knew what what it means to
to technically multiply a math ah a
matrix
but what does it mean to find eigenvalue
what why is that even a good thing okay
so that i could not understand it and
then
so so the decision to move the technion
was weird in that sense it
worked well but let me but i my point is
if you if a having some
uh some formal education especially in
our field
is important to 99 of the people now to
be clear
if you're that one person that opens
your computer
you read a you know you read articles
day and night
you go and write that code no you don't
need it okay but
but but but but generally speaking if
you see people that were
that were successful dropping out of you
know dropping out of college
and think hey you know i don't need
college
just remember that uh that folks like
bill gates
like like mark zuckerberg those are
folks that have the
u.s equivalent of 800 in the is yeah in
the psychometric exam or
you know whatever their sat number is so
so
it's not that this is impossible but you
really have to be objective with
yourself and say
am i the kind of person that just takes
something on
no training and it just works if you're
that kind of person hey
drop everything don't work you know
spend a year or two working somewhere
just to get the basics
and do whatever you want but if that's
not it then
spend some time at college okay it is
not a bad thing and and pick a good
college
okay don't say and i can say again it's
very it's not politically correct yeah i
i was going i was going to say
i think that yeah here i think there's
two
two main thoughts that i have one is
that you know you're right i think that
a lot of people look at people
and i there's two thoughts that i have
in regards to what you're saying here
one is for you know a lot of people look
at these exemplars like
you know steve jobs bill gates and
zuckerberg and they're saying you know
these these are people that dropped out
of college they
you know the system didn't work for them
and they were it turned out great but
you know people forget that you know
sergey brin and larry page dropped out
of a phd program
and bill gates dropped out of i believe
the third year zuckerberg dropped out of
it out of his second year
after he was all after he already had
like 10 years of computer science
experience under his belt and he was
taking some senior
and graduate school classes so so i
think that there
is you know there are people that have
this misconception that it's
you know okay if if bill gates did it
then i can do it i don't have to even go
study i can just
go and do it on my own and maybe they
can but but but i think it's important
to know realistically what happened and
what
skills really they harnessed and they
did harness a lot of the skills
in academia that led to their success
and the other thing that you're talking
about
i think which is you know i think that
there is also a difference a cultural
difference between going to college and
in the different countries right so in
israel we go
to college after the army it's it's
primarily a professional
mentality you go to college because you
want to gain that professional skills
that's less about
you know personal growth because the
army is responsible for that
but then you have you know for example
in in the us and a lot of other places
where
you know that is the next stepping stone
to maturity after
high school because you don't have that
army so
instead of going at 18 to the army you
go to college and the college experience
there is also very much targeted to your
personal growth and
and making you a balanced human being
and growing you as a person
so i think that it's also extremely
valuable in that sense
but i was just inspired to hear about
your your journey your take
and before we leave i have to ask two
most important questions one is
now in hindsight what would be the most
important advice you would give yourself
if you could go back all the way to
those high school or college days
and then the second question is three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
so in terms of advice uh
i don't know i think that's that's a
non-trivial one
i would just go with a you know with a
trivial don't panic answer
i mean it's super hard to to predict
what the future would
you know i think there's right there's a
saying of it's hard to make predictions
especially about the future
so so so i i would just say
i think in life we typically look at
most of
the decision many of the decisions we
make as hey this is a deal breaker
i'm going to drop out of college this is
going to make or break everything
okay and we tend to look at many
decisions that way
and the truth is that this is more
similar to you know to
making uh an investment in the stock
market or something like that
you actually you know each one of your
smaller decisions actually guide you
through so
if you're going to to make one or two or
three bad decisions
it doesn't matter most of the time
unless it gets you killed or something
but but but actually being able to
consistently make those decisions
is important and you don't need to be
too troubled that one decision you make
is going to break it hey you drop out of
high school you can you can you can redo
that in a couple of months later that's
true for anyone
you drop out of college you can come
back it's not it's not a killer right as
long as
you know as long as you apply logic
i would not even say logic apply a
deterministic and consistent process
that's i i think that's that will get
you much farther than you think okay
so don't panic as great it would have
made the stress levels much lower for me
um in terms of three words so i think
one is uh
i know luck is def definitely a factor
here so i i don't
really know whether you know whether i
am lucky or not
but i feel lucky okay i mean many things
could have gone a
different way and thinking back even
some of the
you know even some of the things that
were not necessarily uh
you know a super fun experience at the
time i know getting rejected
for example i was rejected from the
excellent program at the technion
okay so when that happened i wasn't
super happy okay
but looking back it was a pretty good
thing for me okay i think had this
actually worked out i i think the
overall result may have been actually
much worse than what i
than what i was able to achieve so so
so luck definitely is uh whether i'm
lucky or not i feel lucky which is
interesting
um the the second thing is empathy
and so i don't know i'm not necessarily
always sympathetic
but being able to empathize with what
someone else
feels or you know or or sees is this is
a
i think this is an understated uh
you know this is an understated value
that can really move you forward
the amount of times you talk to someone
else and
you know the difference between
understanding his viewpoint
and not can be the difference between
getting what you want in a
in an hour or a day and having something
never happen at all okay
i think that's something that helped me
when i was a manager but
also helped me much earlier didn't have
that when i was much younger but i think
i think that that green and the last one
is
um that that's going to sound a bit
paradoxical but
i think maybe humbleness and that does
not mean okay i mean i have a huge goal
okay it's not it doesn't mean that i
don't brag about things because
unfortunately i do but it doesn't i
i would i would describe that as tech or
logic humbleness
i think that's something that's really
important for people to you know to be
aware of and that's
the ability to look at the data you have
whether that's your feelings or numbers
or anything else
and to analyze that you know with
calm and be able to say hey you know
what i'm wrong
for example in tech it's super easy
especially as you become more senior
to just get in the room and immediately
think hey i'm smarter than everyone
i'm more senior okay but uh but but
being able to
enter each one of those discussions and
you have tens of those
uh a week now and hundreds of those a
month
being able to walk into such a
discussion and say
listen guys right i'm just hey i know i
made that decision a week ago i'm wrong
and do that
consistently not you know not just once
that is a
i think that that is again that is a
sort of a hidden superpower that if you
have
that you can actually move things much
much faster along
than you could otherwise and if you're
able to implement that in your personal
life it also makes you a
happier person i think i love that yeah
here
thank you so so much for spending this
time with me i think your journey is
incredible i think your
insights your humbleness and your your
very open-minded outlook um
i think that a lot of people you know go
through some experiences
and obviously you've succeeded in in
whatever path you've chosen
to to take but then they they go and
they recommend that path and i love that
your recommendation is don't listen to
my recommendation
you know every person has a different
path don't panic and
you know remain humble remain
open-minded a
you know i i think that's that's really
the key and and as we grow to a more
globalized world where information is
accessible
really to to to with a you know split of
a second
and curiosity and passion is what drives
us but it's also the idea that the world
is changing
literally every second and you know i
don't know what
is going to be my next career right now
i'm a software engineer who knows
you know maybe i'll be a farmer in this
new type of farming thing right
because the world is just changing and
you know we just have to keep
discovering ourselves
so thank you for taking the time to
speak with me and stay safe and stay
[Music]
healthy